hello and welcome to inside the Oscars
I'm Rachel Smith in today's best picture
close-up discover how director Martin
Scorsese and actors Leonardo DiCaprio
and Jonah Hill went wild to tell the
saga of the wolf of Wall Street when I
was reading the book I thought this
can't possibly be true if it is true
first of all I didn't I couldn't believe
the guy who wrote it was gonna be alive
at the end of it and if it is true it's
wildly embellished and I spoke to the
FBI agent who arrested Jordan and he
said I will tell you this I tracked this
guy for 10 years every single thing in
this book is true every outlandish
coincidence every insane level of drug
taking the money everything is there
it's all true I didn't respond right
away to the material I couldn't find a
way in yet on it because of similarity
of the work that have done before in
other pictures and so if we're gonna do
that I thought well I'm gonna have to
really find a way to break a structure
somehow or evolve a style finally I said
all right I think I got the idea of how
to tell the story to ignore the
conventionality of certain story aspects
in fact just drop them so I had two that
we were in our script meetings and I
would anything that I found that I'd
seen before as let's lose it I started
to fight the continuity of it I said
what if it's just inside the mindset of
this world
what if it's inside the mindset of the
people want to take advantage of you and
me and want to beat you out of your
money and laugh at you when they do you
know they may change later on in life
and everything meantime you're hurt but
why don't we just stay with them wait
and then suddenly you turn around and
realize we would with in a sense with
monsters I was just taken by
you know Jordan's honesty and look he
looks at this as a very isolated time in
his life so he was incredibly forthright
with all this information not only in
the novel but for me as an actor
incredibly embarrassing details about
his life and to be able to go in there
with the idea that we're not gonna do
something conventional and every time we
tried you know our our characters
steered to some sort of you know
artificial sentimentality or some
motivation for his actions we would chop
it off at the head and then you know
bring him right back down to you know
who he is on a very authentic level and
the way Jordan betrayed himself in the
book it's a very hedonistic amoral time
period in his life so you know every
time we started going in that direction
all of us would you know say no you know
we've seen this before we seen so forth
I love three things I love my country I
love Jesus Christ and I love making
people rich this is a guy with no
impulse control you know I recognize who
this guy is and I really wanted the
chance to bring him to life and these
guys cared a lot more about becoming
excessively wealthy than what they had
to do to get there or who they had to
hurt to get there you don't see the wake
of destruction the ship just keeps
moving forward these guys just keep
going constantly forward without any
regard for anyone except themselves
that's the that's what we're we're
trying to capture in that culture you
know I mean something about the darker
nature of all of us to make sure you
don't miss any of the behind the scenes
action on Oscar Sunday
check out the Oscar buzz page on Oscar
com